bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct pour ce débat sur rt
france ce matin emmanuel macron qui se
rend donc demain à belfort pour
officialiser le rachat de la branche
nucléaire de general electric par par
edf avec en toile de fond cette question
évidemment de la réindustrialisation et
la question énergétique en 2017 il était
candidat en marche à l'époque il
promettait une reconquête industrielle
il a réitéré cette promesse en octobre
dernier écouter
la stratégie pour 2030 doit nous
conduire à investir 30 milliards d'euros
pour répondre à une sorte de déficit de
croissance français et un investissement
massif dans notre stratégie d'innovation
et d'industrialisation
cécile que karman comment ce que vous
jugez le bilan industriel d'emmanuel
macron
force est de constater qu'il n'est pas
en tout cas une réussite dans la
réindustrialisation et le maintien des
sites industriels dans notre pays vous
en avez une mire et quelques-uns à
travers votre reportage je pourrais vous
en citer deux autres au coeur de ma
région la problématique de luxair qui a
fermé qui est aujourd'hui en situation
de reprise par justement l'action de ses
salariés mais également en savoir avec
la fermeture annoncée du site de
ferropem et donc des manques en termes
de production d'aluminium dans notre
pays je pourrais vous insistez beaucoup
d'autres mais force est de constater que
le bilan d'où les 5 ans est loin d'être
un maintien de l'outil industriel et
encore moins le développement de l'outil
industriel français qui rappelons le
créent la richesse de notre pays crée
les emplois et permet bien évidemment
d'anticiper de vincent chauve et on a vu
quelques propositions 30 milliards dans
son plan france 2030 est ce que selon
vous c'était la hauteur des promesses
alors vous l'avais dit il ya un vrai
problème c'est le niveau de déficit
extérieur
effectivement le fait qu'il y a eu des
airs emblématiques ou des fermetures
emblématique du sinn on en a tous connu
un peu partout en france ces dernières
années y compris dans ma ville a autant
mais ce qu'il faut voir c'est qu'il ya
eu globalement ce qui va être annoncé à
belfort en est symbolique un changement
de paradigme emmanuel macron à à
lui-même changer parce que la société a
changé suite à deux crises la crise de
l'environnement la transition
énergétique et ça c'est le fait que les
turbines d'alstom qui avait été vendu à
general electric vont redevenir
française puisque le débat les vallées
racheter c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
l'emploi à belfort et pour notre aussi
transition énergétique grâce au
nucléaire la deuxième c'est la crise
sanitaire ou accule finalement notre
industrie qui pouvait paraître archaïque
sur le territoire hier les au début des
années 2000 la france sans usine c'était
un peu le modèle de développement
économique de la france bien avec les
rupture de chaîne d'approvisionnement
on voit des chefs d'entreprise qui
prennent la décision au contraire devant
relocaliser et là aussi le gouvernement
accompagne notamment avec france relance
et puis maintenant avec france 2030
accompagnent très fortement les
relocalisations et là aussi on a des
exemples dans nos circonscriptions par
exemple à ottawa où
une usine belge qui ferait des matelas
et qui avaient des matelas produits au
canada et bien a compris que avec les
difficultés logistiques que pouvait
entraîner est la crise sanitaire et puis
que la mondialisation
cette limite de relocaliser une partie
de la production sur nos territoires
donc je pense qu'il ya quelque chose qui
s'amorce à la fois grâce à l'action du
gouvernement mais aussi grâce à ces deux
crises sanitaires et énergétique qui est
plutôt positive et qui doit être
accompagnée sur le prochain quinquennat
par le gouvernement est-ce que 30
milliards ça vous paraît ça vous paraît
à la hauteur de 2 de l'ambition en tout
cas de réindustrialisation du pays
cécile queille karman
marine le pen pour l'essentiel
je crois même qu au delà des montants de
ces l'utilisation qui vont être faites
parce que vous savez si on rajoute
d'abord jeu je regrette tout de même
qu'il ait fallu attendre une crise
sanitaire pour sur mon compte que dans
notre pays on avait besoin d'une
industrie parce que je crois qu'il n'y a
pas besoin at on des crises je disais un
pays a besoin de s'industrialiser
effectivement c'est l'échelle de ce
quinquennat c'est la succession de
politique économique ça a été rappelé
qu'ils ne visaient pas à développer
l'industrie voire à des usines is est
entre guillemets nos territoires que
nous payons aujourd'hui donc il y as
besoin de réamorcer et de permettre
effectivement leur déploiement donc la
question du financement c'est que si mal
mâcon mais 30 milliards pour continuer
ce qui a été fait et du crédit impôt
recherche qui n'a pas les effets
escomptés et plusieurs rapports l'ont
démontré parce que l'on a besoin bien
évidemment de rien du trésor paix et de
mieux former d'accompagner les emplois
dont il y aura besoin de main pour que
celles ci puissent être efficaces et se
maintenir a bien évidemment dans le
temps donc on a besoin d'avoir ces
enjeux là on a besoin de repenser la
formation on a besoin et chefs des
régions de repenser le crédit bancaire
parce qu'aujourd'hui on a aussi des
chefs d'entreprise qui quand ils veulent
se réinstaller son face à la difficulté
du crédit bancaire on a besoin c'est
surtout d'une véritable stratégie
nationale à long terme avec et c'est la
proposition que fait fabien au sein d'un
véritable ministère de l'industrie qui
repose bien évidemment toute la question
y compris de la chaîne industrielle en
amont comme en aval parce que dans nos
territoires et monsieur vous êtes maire
d'autun jeu sénatrice de la loire je
crois que nous avons des les territoires
qui vivons à la réactivité de cette sous
traitance et donc quand on un donneur
d'ordre qui vient à être défaillant ce
sont derrière des dizaines de tpe de tpe
et de pme et les emplois qui vont bien
évidemment richesses qui sont également
détruites donc on a besoin de
retravailler avec un l'état faure
stratège en matière de développement
industriel et ensuite des régions qui en
matière de développement économique en
mobilisant bien évidemment les
différents financements nécessaires tant
pour l'installation que la formation
peuvent travailler ce maillage joli de
dire industrielle dans les différentes
filières vincent chauvet vous parliez du
déclencheur de la prise de conscience en
tout cas qu a été la crise sanitaire on
sue bien que le gouvernement avait
incité certains entrepreneurs à
fabriquer des masques en france et
aujourd'hui certains nous disent qu'ils
sont obligés de mettre la clé sous la
porte parce que les français préfèrent
toujours acheter moins cher en chine
comment est ce que est ce qu'il ne
faudrait pas sanctuariser finalement
cette question essentielle de la santé
oui il y avait filiale stratégique et
selon ses filiales qui identifie le pôle
en france 2030 le nucléaire en fait
partie mais d'autres d'autres filières
également avec un certain nombre d'axés
stratégiques qui sont définies par
l'état effectivement 30 milliards
d'euros qui sont consacrés à ces
filières stratégiques
je pense que il faut pas tout promettre
de l'état ou des collectivités
territoriales on a paradoxe ceci en
france c'est qu'on est un des pays
d'europe les plus taxés où les
entreprises sont le plus taxé presque 60
milliards de plus que l'allemagne et de
l'autre côté où il ya aussi le plus des
publics aux entreprises dont certaines
même si je ne partage pas ce que je
viens de dire ma collègue sénatrice de
la loi mais dont certaines n'ont pas
fait elle preuve de lors de leur
efficacité le crédit impôt recherche
peut être contesté mais elle est quand
même une lisibilité et ne doit être
touchée que d'une main tremblante à mon
avis parce que il y à aussi ce troisième
défaut dans notre pays que l'on à une
instabilité législatives qui fait que
les chefs d'entreprise sont perdus mais
en tout cas qui créent l'emploi ou qui
le détruit c'est d'abord le décideur
économique le chef d'entreprise et donc
je pense qu'il y à vraiment à regarder
comment on permet d'avoir une
compétitivité en france
sur sur le la fabrication ça passe par
les primes énergie là encore le
nucléaire est une solution ça passe
aussi par la question de la fiscalité
pas seulement sur les salaires mais la
fiscalité globale avec des ddd des taxes
qui comme la c30 quand même assez macho
et donc il y aura probablement à faire
cet équilibrage son prochain quinquennat
c'est en tout cas ce que souhaite bruno
le maire pour pour le futur qui a classé
présent de la république est réélu sont
les pilules l'argument est l' équilibre
cette qualité est elle pour avoir des
entreprises plus agile plus compétitive
dans ce nouvel environnement mondial
justement on va écouter bruno le maire
pour lui la reconquête industrielle
devrait être la grande cause du prochain
quinquennat vous l'avait dit et doit
donc figurer en bonne place dans le
programme des lecteurs du futur candidat
probablement emmanuel macron regarder
nous avons fait le choix d'un mauvais
modèle où les grands groupes vont
produire à l'étranger tout le monde doit
s'y mettre les responsables politiques
mais aussi les responsables économiques
qui doivent prendre leurs
responsabilités
il faut que ce soit une mobilisation
générale sur cette reconquête
industrielle
cécile que karman vous disiez qu'il
fallait
remettre en place un ministère de
l'industrie c'est aussi ce que demande
france industries inquiets qui
représente évidemment le le secteur
france industrie réclament également un
geste fiscal beaucoup plus conséquent
les fabien roussel lui veut nationaliser
les entreprises
stratégiques
est ce que ce serait la solution selon
vous
nous nous disons qu'il ya effectivement
quelques entreprises à renationaliser
pour y compris permettre de mieux
accompagner le développement industriel
c'est notamment le cas dans le secteur
pardon des banques et des assurances
c'est aussi pouvoir m or à un moment
donné de situation de fragilité des
grandes entreprises pour leur permettre
de rester et permettre à l'état d'être
présent bon moi je je souris à la phrase
de bruno le maire parce que je trouve ça
formidable qu'un ministre attendre le
mois de janvier 2022 la fin d'un
quinquennat pour dire cela alors qu'il a
été et j'ai envie de dire sur tous les
bancs du groupe communiste au groupe
l'est républicain
interpellées depuis le début du
quinquennat justement sur la nécessité
le besoin d'une politique industrielle
je partage ce que dit mon collègue maire
maire d'autun mais je veux rassurer
d'abord bien évidemment ce ne sont pas
les collectivités l'état qui feront tout
parce que je crois que chacun a ses
métiers et donc les chefs d'entreprise
ont le leur y compris dans les
responsabilités en revanche vous savez
aussi bien que moi quand une entreprise
est en difficulté les salariés et chefs
d'entreprise se retourne vers les
collectivités
et pouvoirs publics quant à chef
d'entreprise veut s'installer il
commence par venir voir le maire de la
commune air même s'il n'est pas
forcément celui ci qu'elle plus de
compétences en la matière quand je pars
venir voir le maire et donc je crois que
ça ce sont des réalités canton comme je
dis que oui il a besoin réellement
d'avoir les pouvoirs publics à
l'offensive sur cette question à c'était
en ce sens après bien évidemment il ne
s'agit pas de s'ingérer dans le
fonctionnement toutes les entreprises en
revanche est sûre ça je suis
intransigeante et je les assume c'est
que quand on reçoit de l'argent public
oui on a des on a des comptes à rendre
la des objectifs atteints parce je suis
convaincu que l'entreprise a une
responsabilité sociale et territoriale
dans le développement un territoire dans
le bien-être des femmes et des hommes et
des salariés et que aujourd'hui trop
dead qui ont été accordés n'ont pas fait
leur efficacité dans le dans ce type de
développement donc je ne dis pas que le
chef d'entreprise sont responsables de
rien nous avons très certainement
commande vous et moi sur le département
de la loire mais quand londres avait
continué de charrier je crois en fait
une très belle sont une très belle
entreprise qui a fait sa démonstration
pendant la crise sanitaire dont oui on a
besoin d'accompagner ces entreprises qui
seront demain les fleurons de notre pays
comment rendre des comptes quand on
perçoit des subventions quand on est une
entreprise
vous savez c'est très simple il suffit
au départ de se mettre d'accord sur des
critères ils ont fait un pacte mais
gagnant gagnant la question n'est pas de
mettre au pilori tel ou tel d'abord
parce que y compris en 2-3 faisant des
choses peuvent évoluer mais je crois
qu'on a eu on a besoin d'un bon dîner
d'avoir des pactes gagnant gagnant avec
l'entreprise on vous l ai simplement on
vous a dit ça marche on continue sa
marche pas on arrête les jours je pense
que
farid et devoir inventer toujours des
grands systèmes avec des grandes comité
des grandes commissions je crois qu'en
tout cas à l'échelle des régions à
l'échelle des intercommunalités on peut
faire de l'efficacité
et donc on va sur un pacte gagnant
gagnant et en vrai on les connaît ceux
qui jouent le jeu et ceux qui ne jouent
pas le jeu donc voilà et à l'échelle de
l'état bien un contrôle parlementaire
renforcer sur l'utilisation des
différents crédits d'impôt et puis
peut-être faire un peu moins un peu plus
efficace et un peu plus ciblées vincent
s'affûtera moins chère sarah mènera plus
de cotisations sociales ça permettra de
faire plus de services publics dont au
sto si free dont sont aussi friands les
grands industriels de notre pays qui
vincent sauver votre réaction à la
proposition de fabien roussel de
renationaliser certaines entreprises
clés
alors
là où je suis d'accord avec ma collègue
communiste c'est que c'est une question
aussi de l'aménagement du territoire il
faut le redire parce que c'est assez peu
connu mais ce sont les territoires hors
gros qui sont des territoires les plus
industriels la loire la saône et loire
sont des territoires très industrielle
les métropoles ne sont pas les grandes
ils ne sont pas là où sont les usines
françaises et donc il y a un vrai enjeu
et quand on parle de legé les jaunes
d'oeufs de lait lionel de
l'ile-de-france téléphérique est un vrai
enjeu en france l'installation et de
maintien le tissu industriel dans nos
territoires ruraux bon ensuite en
revanche je suis en désaccord avec la
proposition du prince table communiste
de nationaliser un certain nombre
d'entreprises la cour des comptes vient
de rendre un rapport extrêmement
intéressant sur le la doctrine de l'état
actionnaire on existait relativement est
même parfaitement obsolète et je pense
que la solution pour maintenir des
usines en france et de l'emploi
industriel ce n'est pas la
nationalisation
et on voit que le plan ait public en
annonçant le rachat à general electric
de la branche turbines mais en la
faisant rachetée par edf qui fasse comme
une entreprise avec un certain de de
capitaux publics montrent qu'on peut
être pragmatique et que sur des seuils
des stratégies que l'état doit
intervenir plus lourdement mais en
revanche on devient un peu du sud est
née sur la banque ou l'assurance je ne
pense pas que ce soit comme le propose
le candidat communiste la
nationalisation qui soit la solution on
recevrait que ce fût ce sujet est très
vaste on va finir par ce qu'a proposé
jean michel blanquer sur les
mathématiques parce que france industrie
réclame justement à ce que les élèves
fassent des mathématiques c'est très
important pour pour la suite évidemment
écouter ce qu'a dit le ministre il a
finalement apporté une réponse aux
critiques puisque les filles aujourd'hui
ne font plus de maths et donc elles ne
vont plus dans les filières d'excellence
jean michel blanquer requis veut donc
apporter une réforme à sa réforme vont
regarder
on a mis dans le tronc commun de
première et de terminale un enseignement
scientifique de deux heures il faut
probablement le faire évoluer pour qu'il
y ait plus de mathématiques en son sein
pour la culture mathématique de
l'ensemble des élèves à vous parler des
des zones rurales il ya aussi l'école
qui est important de finalement pour
pour la suite que pensez vous de ce
revirement en tout cas du ministre de
l'éducation monsieur monsieur chauvet
oui là où c'est important c'est de voir
que les politiques publiques et
éducative mais aussi les politiques
industrielles one impact sur les
questions de genre et quand on voit
des jeunes femmes peuvent se détourner
des mathématiques et bien c'est là où il
faut peut-être corriger le tir parce que
pour l'industrie mais aussi pour le
numérique on les start up on a besoin de
femmes développeuse
aujourd'hui il ya une carence dans ce
domaine on avait réussi au fur et à
mesure des années à à casser les
stéréotypes de genre et à faire que les
femmes retournent dans l'informatique
qui était à la base informatique et
était même plus féminin que masculin là
on voit que peut-être par les
mathématiques on est en train de faire
machine arrière et il faut d'urgence et
équilibrée pour pour assurer la
pérennité notamment deux de nos
développeurs mais aussi de nos
ingénieurs heureux dans les usines
france est de 2 l'an c'est ce que carmen
une réaction à cette déclaration de
jean-michel blanquer
je crois que c'est important mais vous
savez on va pas revenir sur informe du
mac je crois surtout qu'on a besoin
d'avoir des jeunes qu'ils soient bien
formés autant besoin bien évidemment
excusez moi je ferai peut-être un peu à
l'ancienne et d'avoir un bon
enseignement des lettres des sciences et
des humanités je crois surtout que ça ça
doit nous ramener ça effectivement à ce
que disait mon collègue c'est à dire
comment est ce que l'on évite surtout un
moment donné de faire des inégalités
entre les femmes et les hommes au sein
de certaines grandes filières
d'orientation et de métier demain mais
effectivement mais là permettez moi de
dire je crois que ce n'est pas
simplement la question de cette réforme
du bac on a un véritable problème dans
notre pays sert que pourquoi est-ce-que
on a pu abandonner aussi industrie de
cette façon assez parce que la culture
scientifique et technologique a reculé
très fortement des dés l'école dans la
société bref là je ne suis pas en train
de responsabiliser tel talent c'est un
fait je crois plus plus générale et
effectivement je crois qu'il faut en
tout cas être très vigilants pour que
cela soit la sphère de tous demain voilà
j'ai envie de le dire ainsi la sphère de
tous pour pouvoir continuer d'avoir des
salariés et des salariés et e bref des
salariés bien fort mais qui puisse
répondre en tout cas aux grands défis de
demain et on le sait sans révolution
scientifique et technologique nous ne
ferons pas peut-être qu'une encore à
crise sanitaire d'air nous interroge
certaines choses que nous pouvons
parfois entendre effectivement le recul
en tout cas en matière de culture
scientifique largement dans notre
société ce qui nous amène à ma dernière
question à son chauvet sanctuariser la
recherche c'est aussi ce que proposent
certains candidats
oui effectivement il ya une question à
l'école mais aussi dans l'enseignement
supérieur vous savez les anciens élèves
d'écoles de commerce ou d'ingénieurs
genre de parties sont très
minoritairement aller en politique je
vous rassure mais beaucoup allaient dans
le domaine de la finance ensuite on a eu
la start up mais comme vous l'avez dit
le pari est en passe d'être gagnée même
dépassé on a beaucoup de startups
françaises qui sont qu'ils sont mais
qu'ils sont développés de licorne et de
l'eca corne qui sont en train de se
créer et maintenant peut-être que il
faut inciter les jeunes des écoles de
commerces et des écoles d'ingénieurs
demain à retourner vers l'industrie
c'était l'heure le but initial de ces
grandes écoles qui sont pour la plupart
public d'ailleurs pourcel d'excellence
et donc les polytechniciens pas
forcément dans la finance n'est dans la
silicon valley mais reste en saône et
loire où dans la loi pour faire tourner
il faut les rendre attractives en tout
cas merci beaucoup merci à tous les deux
merci vincent chauvet merci merci
beaucoup cécile kuperman d'avoir
participé à ce débat sur la
réindustrialisation de la france ce
matin sur rtl france